every now and then I come across a story
that's just so extraordinary it's so
stimulating it gives me the
understanding that restrictions may very
well only be in our minds and that so
much more is actually possible most of
the time platitudes aren't Pinterest
posters or magnets on your mom's fridge
offer that sweet release of love and
support during a tough time like writing
your next exam running a marathon or
doing anything that really challenges
you but the story I have right here is
far more captivating far more motivating
than a quote over a sunset and I'm just
really excited to share it with you
welcome to my last episode of this
incredible experience my second season
on YouTube not normal because of this
mulraney secrets this reflection not
switching strangers sake
this is my last seed I can't believe I'm
actually saying that I really know it's
in yeah but I'm pretending like I taint
this weak seed is from Godwin in Nigeria
that says together we should illustrate
the future of humankind and if you're
still confused as toward the seed or
entire not normal shows all about that's
totally cool
I built this global map which you can
find on not normal show calm where you
plant a seed which is an unfinished idea
in your city each week I choose a new
seed applied to that city and completed
with you
Godwin and his crew in Nigeria called
themselves the critics company they're a
group of eighteen year old boys that
went massively viral recently for
shooting these incredible sci-fi shorts
with nothing more than their smartphones
which took them weeks to edit due to
their extremely slow rendering
capabilities on their outdated laptop
through all the restrictions they work
has already seen them invited to the
Governor's House
on the Ted stage covered by CNN African
news al-jazeera and reaching Hollywood
impressed upon the likes of Olivia world
- JJ Abrams
- Ryan colony and more technology has
been an incredible enabler when it comes
to big dreams big dreamers if you have
the world you now have the immense power
to propel the way technology pushes us
forward in what we know and outward in
who we may reach in ways that have never
been possible before and with this there
is
of opportunity begin to fade into the
distance if you didn't have the chance
before you may very well have the chance
now it just all depends on you and how
hard you willing to work and Godwin and
his coworkers are a beautiful example of
this the system is really slow like it
takes time to render I was five minutes
show swim coaches to come like almost to
this mean that the first thing I did
when I saw this video and saw the laptop
that they were editing on and the
struggles that they were going through I
contacted my Rainey who framed that
recent said Colin who has a direct line
with his guys at Maine Gary he's
incredibly fast processing monster
computers used by the likes of Marcus
brown me Dave Mouse PewDiePie and many
other massive players and I arranged to
send them their own main gear machine
which we shipped from New York to
Nigeria
[Music]
package today I thank you guys so so
much thank you very much but that's not
the main thing on this machine I
attached a small USB Drive USB Drive
contains something very special I have
to been approached my thoughts around
writing art and self-expression through
the words of one guy his name is Jason
Silva he comes with many different
titles but maybe there will be inspiring
futurists and deep-rooted anyways it
never crossed my mind that I'd be able
to meet him but through a moment of
serendipity a mutual friend random mini
connector thanks
kind of tickles
[Music]
so much that I wanted to ask him but
this was the time I thought what a great
idea would be to link him in with our
seat therefore I asked him the most
unanswerable question that we all face
yo Jason yes Dan
explain the way in which you see the
world in a hundred years well I think in
a hundred years this is what's on the
USB Drive he's answer the ability for
these students in Nigeria to create the
visuals to depict this unimaginable and
answerable Jason Silva's hypothesis of
the world in a hundred years time this
is most definitely the toughest most
creative most out of the box thinking
brief that any visual effects artist
would ever have to face and I've
challenged these 18 year-old kids in
Nigeria with nothing but these
smartphones to showcase to you watching
this film this immense and unbelievable
ability to be able to create something
way beyond what one would expect from
you enjoy well I think in a hundred
years the world is going to be
unrecognizable look how fast we've
gotten here just to get a sense of
perspective a young kid in South Africa
with a smart phone in his pocket has
better communications and technology
than a head of state had 25 years ago
understanding the pace of change
understanding how the supercomputers
shrank the devices in our pockets you
can extrapolate then that in a hundred
years from now well these supercomputers
in our hands our smartphones will shrink
down to blood cell sized devices that
will go in our bodies and brains reverse
engineering us from inside out what does
this mean well it means a massive
upgrade in our cognition and our
creativity I see us essentially as
speciated into a kind of techno
biological hybrid of sorts a cyborg so
to speak
is code we are alphabetic all the way
down our genes or little software
programs and our capacity to reprogram
biology is advancing at the same
exponential race that we've already seen
with information technology so if you
think of consciousness or the contents
of mind as a pattern of information as
many thinkers do then once we have
something that can compute pattern of
information of that size then we can
kind of perform a kind of mind uploading
and when we move beyond biology and
entropy well then he'll we can live in
the virtual universe yeah
where does empathy play a role made us
vulnerability play a role humans have a
desire an implicit desire to to connect
each of us is born alone and dies alone
we all have our own experience but what
we want more than anything is to have
shared experiences with others but
Terence Mckenna said that virtual
reality when it fully matures will
transform human empathy and intimacy
because he says right now if I want to
share my deepest insides I bring you to
my room
you know I show you my posters and my
books and the songs that make my soul
sing but when virtual reality fully
flourishes I'll bring you into Mike's
galaxy
I'll bring you into my mind when we make
love today we rub our bodies together
trying to merge but with future AI I'll
be able to like actually rub up against
the essence of another person I'll be
able to touch somebody's soul like ribs
Tomas
yeah ribs the mascots yes yes yes you
can think of us as self divining beings
we make ourselves
that's a beautiful that's a beautiful
thing
amazing it's perfect ending dude I can't
even begin to describe how much I've
learned about myself on this journey but
all I can say is that I'm super excited
to share the next phase of my career
with you which is the reason why I have
now recently moved to Los Angeles my
career my life everything has just come
together to this point right here right
now and I am so incredibly grateful I am
so so grateful to every single one of
you that has watched any of my videos
anyone that's commented I am super happy
then there are so many incredible ideas
on the not normal map on the seed map if
you planted the seed don't worry that
idea has not gone to waste I'm going to
make a video where we explain exactly
what's going to happen next with the
site and those ideas are deeply rooted
and I'm definitely gonna sprout into
incredible films so yeah just wait for
that video for me to explain exactly
what's gonna happen next and then lastly
I just want to thank one brand that has
been supporting me and a sponsored me
throughout this entire not normal show
epidemic sound if you don't know
whatever name it sound is epidemic sound
provides high quality original in big
bold letters
that's really important music and
effects for the creator community with
over 30,000 different songs and 60,000
sound effects all curated in-house
they're a really novel business that has
become a new opportunity for musicians
has become a new opportunity for
producers and artists to make money from
their music I really love about epidemic
is that they offer all the tracks steps
so you can break it down from baseline
to melody to vocal and then utilize only
one little section to make sure that
your music sounds unique a small little
section or if you really like the track
but you needed an instrumental without
the drums epidemic as you come and I've
never really worked with a brand that
has given me so much creative freedom
before and just has been a really warm
supporting community of friendship so if
you support me please go and support
them as always I've linked them below
other than that don't forget your
awesome guru this isn't the end I will
see you on Tuesday I'll be uploading
another film something completely
different something new and I've already
said you're awesome but I'll say it
again you're awesome